pues estamos hablando de una persona con
una enorme experiencia en el terreno
deportivo y también olímpico como has
dicho
hashimoto participó en tres juegos
olímpicos de invierno como patinadora de
velocidad sobre hielo e incluso se llevó
una medalla de bronce en albertville 92
también ha participado en tres ediciones
de los juegos de verano como ciclista la
última vez en atlanta 96 siendo ya
parlamentaria en japón
y es que casi moto también tiene una
larga experiencia como administradora
como política además de haber sido
presidenta de la federación de patinaje
sobre hielo del japón ha sido ministra a
cargo de los juegos olímpicos ha sido
ministra para el empoderamiento de la
mujer y ha sido también ministra de
estado a cargo de impulsar la igualdad
ella mismo ha dicho al ser elegida que
la decisión de elegir la idea de hecho
responde a la necesidad de impulsar la
igualdad en japón después de los
comentarios sexistas de su predecesor
yoshiro mori le obligaron a dimitir la
semana pasada en ese sentido desde luego
así moto se antoja como la candidata
idónea para sustituirlo
así es andrés ya hablamos entonces de
quiénes hashimoto pero le pregunto cuál
es el principal reto que le espera a
ella
pues no va a tener nada fácil en primer
lugar va a tener que convencer a los
propios japoneses del positivo de
organizar estos juegos olímpicos porque
las últimas encuestas hablan del 70 80
por ciento de la ciudadanía
expresando su deseo del que o bien se
aplazan de nuevo estos juegos aunque se
cancelen definitivamente lo mismo pasa
con las empresas patrocinadoras
compañías japonesas que están apoyando
económicamente estos juegos olímpicos y
que no ven claro que puedan celebrarse
con seguridad en este momento de
pandemia global en el gobierno japonés
el comité organizador de tokio 2020 el
comité olímpico internacional insisten
en que los juegos van a comenzar en la
fecha prevista el 23 de julio y han
dicho que la vacunación no va a ser
obligatoria para estar ahí obviamente la
opinión pública tiene muchas dudas al
respecto de esto porque estamos hablando
de que incluso aunque no vaya a público
finalmente a los estadios estos juegos
olímpicos' supondría juntar
en el tokyo a más de 20.000 personas
entre deportistas técnicos personal
federativos etcétera y garantizar que no
se produzca que no se produzcan
contagios en cadena esté ahora mismo
obviamente se antoja desde luego como un
reto música así es andrés gracias por
toda la información